okay um good evening everybody and
welcome to this evening's meeting of
planning and development management
committee just by
my introduction my name's aiden williams
and i'm the committee chair also present
this evening are councillor ben hartley
who's the committee vice chair as well
as offices from the council's planning
service legal services and democratic
and governance services
um and in addition to that are also
present are the voting members of the
committee
um
we will now just before we turn to the
business of tonight's meeting i should
just announce as well that this meeting
is being recorded as well as being um
live streamed online
um turning to the agenda agenda item
number one is attendances um i should
let the meeting know that council of
wynn stanley has submitted apologies
this evening and is being substituted by
councillor acton thank you for joining
us tonight council of acton
um i have not received any other
notifications of absence
gender item number two is declarations
of interest are there any members
wishing to make a declaration
nope okay agenda item number three the
minutes they've been circulated with the
committee report pack
czech members are happy to accept those
as
councillor thomas is moving to accept
them councillor hartley seconded
take those as approved
agenda item number four questions from
members of the public haven't received
any
questions prior to the committee meeting
tonight
um number five is the additional
information report which has been
circulated via email earlier today as
well as there being paper copies
provided for the meeting this evening
then gender item of six is applications
with permission to develop
um the first application that we will
consider this evening is 105 350
35 grayson's road in hail which is on
page 55 of the committee report before
we hear from speakers the
application is going to be introduced by
ms cauley
thank you chairman
this application is for the erection of
a part single part two story side and
rear extension a loft conversion rear
garden terrace and other external
alterations following demolition of the
existing rear garage and conservatory
there's been one objection from a
neighboring property and the application
has been called in by the council mrs
young
the slideshow
show shows the existing and proposed
plans and elevations and photographs of
the rear of the property and the
relationship with adjacent properties
including number 37 graysons road from
which objections have been received
regarding loss of immunity and design
concerns
however it is considered that the
proposed extensions and alterations
would be acceptable in terms of their
design and visual immunity and would
have no unacceptable impact on the
residential immunity of neighbouring
properties he's therefore recommended
that permission is granted subject to
appropriate conditions thank you
chairman
thank you ms coley um
speaking against this application will
be councillor young
thank you for joining us counselor you
have five minutes to speak
if you do run over time i'll just
politely ask that you wrap up your
contribution thank you
thank you for letting me speak anyway um
mrs jankum who lives next door in number
37
and asked me to speak on her behalf
is unable to come here tonight so i've
got a short statement from her which i'd
like to just read out first
she did actually write a couple of quite
long
emails in i don't know whether anyone
i've assumed that you've had a chance to
to have a look at the
the previous correspondence in this
anyway what she says is
we are saddened that our visual immunity
and severe loss of light into our main
kitchen dining room and living area has
not been fully considered
see the photographs submitted
any light into the roof light we had put
in our sitting room extension will now
be severely blocked by the proposed
double height extension
as it will project beyond the roof light
we do not feel our line of sight and
right to light especially in main living
area has been adequately considered
we will in effect live in a brick tunnel
it is totally out of character
a real double story extension has not
been allowed on any other property on
the road
thus it would be setting a precedent for
over development of the area
we understand the need and desire for
the extension but feel some compromise
needs to be made regarding the upper
story
so we are not so severely and adversely
affected
our quality and enjoyment of our life
here
will be greatly adversely altered
hoping some satisfactory amendments can
be made
that's actually what what she said and
i've been around and i've had a a look
at the
at the house from inside and
i can
understand
in a way what she is complaining about
it has been admitted
that there will be a degree of
overshadowing and loss of light to
number 37
should this building take place with
both the side kitchen window and the
roof light being affected and i can
understand why mrs jankum is so
concerned
i also feel that it's sad that the
proposed developers in number 35 have
never approached their neighbors to
discuss this application
tellingly mrs jenkins fears that she
will be condemned to live in permanent
shadow and darkness should this
extension be built
i would actually challenge the statement
on page 65 paragraph 41
that the proposed development will not
have any unacceptable impacts on the
residential amenity of neighboring
properties as it will certainly block a
considerable amount of light to number
37
and will stand proudly and visibly above
its neighbors
dominating the whole area of this part
of grayson's road and the considerable
number of dwellings in san diego avenue
below
thank you for letting me speak
thank you councillor um speaking in
favor of the application is toby taylor
um thank you for joining us this evening
mr taylor if you
have three minutes to speak to committee
if you can just make sure that your
microphone's on so the end of it should
be
glowing red really if you press
yeah
is that okay can you hear me
okay thank you chair um the applicants
would wanted to deliver this statement
but unfortunately one of them has
contracted covid and they asked me
instead and do you know my name is toby
tyler i'm an architect and their agent
they first viewed the property in 2018
fell in love with the property and its
location
despite it needing modernization
they moved in later that year their
intentions to provide sufficient living
accommodation for a young growing family
for the next 20 plus years
the brief was to provide a kitchen
family living area playroom utility room
drying area
cloakroom bike garden store all the
usual things a family need
including five good sized bedrooms for
themselves two or possibly three
children and an elderly relative
and the guest room
in october 2020 we submitted a planning
application based on examples of
recently extended properties in grey
sands road and the haven
the proposal included a single story
side and rear extension plus a loft
conversion with built up gables
and a rear-facing dormer the planning
officer rejected this proposal because
it affected the privacy of property
along sandy lee road aspects did not
comply with spd4 and the appearance
affected the uniformity of grayson's
road we agreed and withdrew the
application in 2000 in early 2021
working closely with the planning
officer over a five-month period we
redesigned the proposal we took note of
his comments and amended the proposals
accordingly
a revised proposal was submitted in july
2021
based on further comments from the
neighbor and the planning officer more
adjustments were made resulting in the
proposal before you
the first floor extension has been
shortened alterations to the front
television elevation have can be have
been omitted
side windows given obscured glass and
privacy screens erected at each end of
the terrace accessing the garden
the hipped and pitched roof line is
retained with a central section of flat
roof which will make the roof no higher
than the existing ridge as a result the
loft conversion is considerably smaller
and the original dormer emitted
altogether in favor of roof lights
we've accepted a reduction in the number
of good-sized bedrooms from five to four
the loft will be used as a study as one
parent now works from home full time
the front elevation and roof line retain
the appearance of the existing house and
the grey sounds road street scene from
sandy lee road the ground floor
extension will be obscured by the
natural change in level fencing and
planting the first floor will be visible
as it is now
in his report the planning officer
answers the comments raised in detail
and in it is unnecessary for me to
repeat them here
the claims of loss of light visual
intrusion overshadowing distance to
boundaries etc are all dealt with
he concludes by recommending a
conditional approval
which we hope the planning committee
will endorse
thank you
thank you mr taylor thank you um are
there any members looking to open the
discussion councillor walton
thank you um i've got a lot of sympathy
with uh what counselor young has said i
also visited the house i stood at the
sink at the side in the kitchen which is
uh looks out of the window on the side
of the house um
at number 37
uh it's the main window
um out of the kitchen
uh whilst i was there you could see a
nice big patch of blue sky
and
it was a pleasant place to be they spend
an awful lot of time in their kitchen as
most people do
and if this proposal goes ahead
then
that same view will be replaced by a big
brick wall
and i don't think that's
acceptable um i feel that
they um
you know everybody loves the house that
they
live in or they want to buy
and obviously we've heard that they're
going to um you know the people have
moved in who moved in at number 35 and
they love that you know they they love
the house now they're seeking to change
it
um
and
unfortunately what they're planning is
going to make the people at number 37
love their house
rather less
and i think the you know on on balance
the invasion that loss of light from the
kitchen um means that i really feel that
this
is unacceptable in terms of the design
and visual immunity thank you
thank you councillor
councillor bunting
thank you chairman um
i'm going to disagree
with my colleague who's just spoken i i
think the
the issue is being overstated somewhat
i've also visited the site i have a good
look around it um
i don't believe that the well first of
all the two items separate first of all
the visual disimmunity i think is
substantially overstated i don't think
this will look out of place i don't
think this will cause a problem in terms
of any in terms of visual impact upon
this in terms of the right to review
that's just been mentioned before there
is no such thing in planning is the
right to review you so you don't have
the so okay it might uh so
so i don't think that that argument has
any legs at all
uh in terms of the loss of light uh i
think there may be an impact but i think
that impact will be relatively minimal
i don't think it's going to cause
any substantive
harm to the to the neighbors
certainly nothing that would lead me to
feel that this particular development
was unacceptable so whilst i can
sympathize with the residents people
often dislike it when changes like this
occur i don't think that the changes are
going to occur are going to
cause a significant issue indeed i think
this is an example of the resident
working well with our officers they put
for had a previous uh application as as
was stated
the concerns raised regarding this they
would do it they have revised it uh but
taking both into account the views of
the neighbors and of the planning
officers and have come forward with the
application that we have in front of us
there was a suggestion earlier that we
could have can we have a reasonable
compromise well it's not our job to
bring about reasonable compromise it's
to say yes or to say no it's not a case
of yes we'll allow the planning
application if they make all these
changes but no that's not what we're
about we say yes we say no yeah we can
make a minor change of condition perhaps
but it's not for us to start bargaining
on behalf of one side or another it's to
say yes or no and on this occasion i'm
more than happy to say yes so with that
said chairman i'm more than happy to as
well as supporting i'm happy to uh help
move things along by proposing that we
offer
the grant officer
grant in line with officer
recommendation thank you chairman
thank you um can't see anyone else
indicating just in terms of
what we heard from councillor welton and
also in councillor young's contributions
my understanding is that when i was
reading the committee report there is no
policy breach in terms of immunity and
practice he had planning shaking ahead
there is no policy breach in terms of
any immunity impact and i think what we
heard from mr tyler was quite helpful in
that regard in that he could provide us
with some background information as to
previous attempts to
develop on the site
when the applicants have brought forward
proposals that were not policy compliant
um is there anyone else shouldn't it
cancel the minutes i can see you
indicated
i was just right trying to first i'm i'm
you know a bit on the 50 50 i i have a
lot of um sympathy for the neighbor
um and i feel like
um you know
obviously the applicant hasn't clearly
hasn't there's
councillor this is young has been saying
not going to discuss it with the
neighbor um
i'm a fan of you know if you're going to
do an extension
be neighborly like your neighbors say
you live next door to them um and you're
going to live next door to them
afterwards as well um i know that
obviously i'm not saying that's a reason
to say yes one day whatever by the way
i'm just saying that it's a it's a
factor that what about how we've landed
up where we are i do feel like um
obviously there is there i think there
is intrusion on
the
neighbour at number 37 um light
i don't think
um
i i don't think it's i don't think it's
okay but i i understand that in terms of
it's the only thing i can see is a loss
of is there is a loss of light and then
we don't have a right to a view but we
do have a right to light and we have um
and that is therefore
a degree of loss of immediacy so i'm not
a fan
but i'm trying to work out where was my
planning reason for saying no at the
moment but i'm not a fan of it
counselor hartley
i don't i don't think there is a
planning reason to say no i think i
think that that
is is the issue here i mean i the report
accepts and i accept that there will be
impact on
um the light to that room there is there
is there is some loss of amenity but not
sufficient to
um to to reject the application uh in my
view so i think i think the significant
point for me is that it's not it's not a
sole window into that room and we've
seen applications like this before and
it seem it seems a bit artificial but
that often is the determining factor so
if it was a the sole window serving that
room then
clearly the the impact of the loss of
light and the outlook would be will be
more significant on the on the light
that would enter that room um but we've
seen applications before where this is
the case and where it's not the sole
window obviously
the room gets light from from other
sources so
um
it would it would be wrong in my view
too
um to reject the application on that
basis when when you know we have allowed
other applications that that have hinged
on a similar a similar issue um
and it does seem harsh but i wouldn't
see a resident in my world the other
week very similar issue um
the side facing window there was the
sole window so we talked that through
and i explained why that might be a
problem um
so you know that is that is the issue in
my view but i can't see any plan i don't
think that gives us a planning reason
to uh to refuse this so i'm
happy to second i think councilor
bunting did move that we accept the
recommendation and i'm happy to second
that future
thank you um councillor
yeah
yeah i just want to clarify where the
additional light is coming from in that
room
there isn't actually another window in
the kitchen specifically the the light
is coming from um you know an extension
which is
a separate room and there's an opening
into that into that room and therefore
that you know it it is quite it is quite
dark in there and will be a lot darker
because of the um you know because of
that with that side window
um having its light restricted and just
sorry just to clarify it is the absence
of light or the lack of light that i'm
objecting to and not the view if you see
what i mean
thank you um
it has been moved and seconded well
emotion has been moved and seconded in
respect to the application is that
anybody wants to speak before we move to
a vote
i can't see anyone indicating um it has
been
proposed and seconded that um
we vote in line with officer
recommendation and grant planning
permission for this application um if
members who are happy to support that
motion can indicate now
yeah and those
i'm not happy to support that motion
okay make that nine to three
um stop motion is carried and permission
for development is granted um
um next application for consideration
this evening is 104 577
um instant well london adjacent to
emerson market which is on page one of
the committee report
and before we hear from speakers
the application is going to be
introduced by ms lowes
thank you
places
so
okay thank you and this application
relates to land adjacent to the market
hall on railway road in amsterdam
the application relates to the
redevelopment of the former outdoor
market at the junction of railway road
greenfield avenue in amsterdam town
centre the character of the area is
mixed with commercial residential and
community uses in the vicinity of the
site
the next two slides are a couple of
photographs of in and around of the site
the first one on the left is the view
down railway road with the application
site on your left and the one on the
right is within the site and you can see
the airstone market hall building
just um here or within the picture
again the amsterdam market hall pic
building here on railway road and and
the next picture is up greenfield avenue
with the with the site again on the left
here
planning permission is sought for a
three-story mixed-use development the
proposed uses include a stall holder
retail space
event space
and which you can see on the site plan
here you have the um hall
hall
stall holders and space here a food
court
and
a children's play area
on the first floor there would be a
business hub and a hotel at second floor
level
the development would have a maximum
height of 8.6 meters with the highest
with the highest part on the railway
road frontage with the massing reduced
to the rear and eastern
side elevations through the use of
setback upper floors
on the railway road frontage a caveman
cafe
is proposed with gated openings
which provide views into the site to the
stall holders and food court areas
a separate formal entrance
to the close to the junction with
greenfield avenue will provide access to
the business hub and hotel rooms on the
upper floors by an accessible lift and
staircase
the development will have a contemporary
design with a layered approach to the
railway road frontage with a horizontal
emphasis over three floors broken up
with the use of different materials
including weathered steel
dark blue terracotta cladding and green
walls
and articulation through the use of
balconies and windows
the site includes no dedicated parking
however the applicant has agreed to fund
a tro to convert one of the general use
on street parking bays on greenfield
avenue and to a space reserved for
disabled users
planning permission was previously
granted for the redevelopment of the
site for a new food hall for food drink
leisure uses including a music area and
retail stall holders and a kids outdoor
play area in 2018
[Music]
the site joins the amsterdam market hall
and end of terrace building which you
can just see here on the plan
and this is three stories in height with
attic accommodation and was constructed
in the interwar period the building has
been identified as a non-designated
heritage asset and significant for its
architectural and historic values
the proposals have been significantly
amended during the consideration of the
application to approve its external
appearance amenity impacts and to
require the funding for the tro
the proposals is is considered to be
acceptable in principle as it comprises
town centre uses on a sustainable
brownfield site and will contribute to
the vitality of amsterdam town centre
it is considered that the scheme
complies with the development plan as a
whole and when taking a straightforward
balance and act of the benefits and
harms of the proposal the benefits of
the scheme are considered to
significantly outweigh any harms that
would arise the application is therefore
recommended for approval subject to
conditions thank you
thank you ms lewis um there's one
speaker to this application speaking in
favor of the application is paul carr
hi mr carr thanks for joining us this
evening um you have three minutes to
speak if you do run over time i'll just
politely ask that you wrap up your
contribution um before you can begin can
you just make sure that the microphone's
on so if you press the button it should
illuminate green i think in the end
yeah thank you
four ah now it's on
it's changed since last time i was in
here anyway um good evening everybody um
i'm paul carr of poor car design and
have been integral to all versions of
the proposals on this site
i remind members that this site already
has consent for a very similar scheme
which was actually taller and wider than
the one that is before you just now
the onset of coved and the devastating
impact on the food and beverage industry
required a rethink
this scheme
has been designed to offer a flexible
solution that can adapt to the
ever-changing impact of the virus
other than full lockdown we can continue
to serve the community safely and in
person with safe well-ventilated open
spaces which will be accessible to all
should a full lockdown hit us
thought has already been given to the
logistics of safe working for staff
operators and delivery partners to
ensure we can remain trading
turning to more usual planning matters
this revised proposal still offers a
fabulous regeneration opportunity for
hermston in a similar way that we've
seen in other urban
centres within the borough
a fresh appraisal of the marketplace
identified additional uses that will now
add to the long-term vitality and
viability of the site
and the goff group's ability to fund
operate and manage a community hub now
including business pods and meeting
spaces to suit an emerging new way of
working
local business groups and workers
who have tired of being at home will
create a day-long creative buzz and help
to kick-start the food and beverage
operators
all of which are selected from a growing
list of local independent traders to
cement this as a fabulous urn from
irmston centric location
also included are a number of bespoke
hotel rooms these will operate as part
of the m41 community and assist in
creating a sustainable destination here
for the longer term
there have been a few comments and
neighbours regarding the description of
contactless check-in to the hotel and
business hub please understand that this
will be a fully staffed fully managed
and monitored facility
contactless is merely a description of a
dedicated app and touchscreen facilities
at reception to assist visitors safety
this has all been explained in detail
within submissions around operations and
management paul danks sales and
operations director is present here
tonight should members have any specific
queries about the ops
in conclusion this is a very similar
proposal to that which already has full
consent a slightly different vibrant mix
of uses completely appropriate for the
town centre
using similar scale and materials to the
consent albeit with the added benefits
of vibrant green walls and a slightly
more distinctive face this is a great
opportunity to welcome huge benefits to
ernst significant employee in investment
job creation and opportunities for local
business and supply chains
all by an award-winning traffic
developer and operator already one of
the largest employers in this borough
i ask that you follow the very clear
recommendation from your professional
team and grant consent for this exciting
opportunity thank you
thank you mr carr
do any members looking to open the
discussion
no
we'll get to council thomas then thank
you
thank you chair i'm very split on this
uh
something needs to be done with the old
marketplace and i think most of the
majority of m41 residents want something
done to it
whether or not they want a
hotel that will bring
potentially 29 vehicles to the area with
no parking at all in the vicinity of it
with a business hub that could increase
that
i'm not so sure
um
the traffic around railway road
greenfield church unfortunately the
photograph
that was shown on the slides must have
been taken about half past nine on a
wednesday afternoon when it wednesday
morning when it was raining because if
you go there on a friday or a saturday
or a sunday the traffic is chaos
the impact on the traffic
will be massive there is nowhere else to
go
one disabled parking bay is nowhere near
enough if you want to make it accessible
it really isn't so i'm torn up to him
because i think
the original plans were
very welcome and very good moving
forward
this is just
to me
i'm gonna have such a big impact on m41
in terms of
residents being able to park the effect
you will have on shops local shops
independent shops in the area not by my
means of market hall but i mean by
people being able to get
into ernst
to
to trade and park
and and get access to them
um
like i say i do think that it needs
something i'm not sure that this is the
right answer
thank you um councillor punting
yes thank you chairman um
distinctive is one of those horrendous
words in planning isn't it it usually
means bloody ugly um
and let's face it that's what it means
in this occasion it is pretty damn
hideous
uh i've seen some ugly buildings in this
planning application in this planning
committee before and i've even voted for
a few of them because there was no real
reason to turn down but
it's a good job all i'll say for the
architect that there is no requirement
in planning to not be uh to actually
make the building look appealing because
he gods it's ugly
having said that and moving on to more
substantive grounds it's difficult to
disagree with anything that my colleague
has just said
yes this site has been here before
numerous times and something needs to be
done with this site and
the area does need to be regenerated
but given the planning
concerns that he raised especially those
surrounding the parking issues which i
will agree with him i've been to this
area many time at the weekend and it is
a living nightmare to find anywhere to
park you know you could be driving
around for some time before you found
anywhere that you can sort of squeeze
your car into
it's a a real
planning problem for this area now if
this was being built with some sort of
parking facility included
i'm not quite sure how you'd do it
unless you're gonna go to great expense
and sort of start digging
um
then that would be a different kettle of
fish i'd be prepared to put aside my
thoughts on the design and appearance of
this facility
um
and accept the regenerative effects of
it
however given the fact that that is not
the case i'm perhaps
very much in a similar position to the
previous speaker i'd love to vote it
down
but on the other hand i'd also love to
take the benefits of it
but am i prepared to inflict the
misery that this will cause in terms of
parking on that area i'm not sure i'm
not sure i will maybe not at this stage
i'm going to listen to some of my
colleagues and find out what they've got
to say but um so i'm not going to
propose refusal at this point but the
parking is a serious issue that all area
already has massive parking problems
especially
when there is so uh you know at the
weekend when if he would turn to shot
but also during the week um
but really at the weekends and this
facility given its nature would have
impact on the weekend it's not just
going to be a weekday thing you know so
talk of business hubs and all the rest
of it if it's good the hotel aspect is
going to create
major parking issues at the weekend when
it when it is at its worst
in that area so i'll wait and see what
my colleagues have to say
thank you german
thank you um council of acton
thank you chair
um i i'm actually supportive of this
development i think it is
definitely needed and it will help the
regeneration
of ernst and i'm absolutely certain of
that that site has been uh empty for for
too long and it is an important
part of the town center
and i think
the the fact that it is a town centre
location
parking yes
it is an issue but it's an issue
everywhere quite frankly particularly in
in town centers and there are quite
large
uh
car parks within the center itself
which can accommodate a lot of
cars
and of course
we we shouldn't
sort of restrict
our
thoughts in terms of
the the parking issue
when we're trying to reduce anyway
journeys within cars um you know we've
all got a commitment
around that
and
um
as has been said
a similar kind of development
um
was agreed previously in the area
and i think people are looking in in
ernst and i live very close to
um
you know this location
and i think a lot of people
would welcome
the development that is being proposed
tonight so with that i would be happy to
move agreement on um
with with the recommendation
thank you councillor and councillor
welton
thank you i'm in um agreement with the
council act and um i think i mean if you
if we want to guarantee lots of
traffic lots more traffic coming to um
what you do you create a development
with lots of parking spaces which
guarantees that lots of people will
drive there now this is a hotel and
you know multi-use facility that will be
advertised as having no parking spaces
so a lot of people will choose not to
access it by car um i think we've seen
references in the plan so in some of
some of the objections that the
residents are
you know have been looking for a parking
scheme from the council for some years
and i think that's the way to address
any parking issue if residents need
permit parking then the council should
be addressing that um that need
and we shouldn't be restricting the
um the regeneration of the area because
of um you know
because of this
requirement that everybody you know that
has people have to be able to drive to
it and have guaranteed parking i mean i
do sympathize with with the residents
but you know and the parking issue but
we have this in a lot of places or you
know around traffic there are simply too
many cars and we can't allow the
development of our borough to be held up
by this this
fascination with the motor car all the
time
um regarding the visual aspect it's
it looks a lot better in 2d than it does
in on flat on on the wandy
the wandy looks absolutely dreadful um
it looks a lot better on here it
does look a bit temporary um
i might have concerns you know
about the energy efficiency of these
materials that are being used and that
kind of thing but i don't really have
any any details about that so i can't
really make an objection on those
grounds thank you
thank you and councillor hartley
thank you i'm quite enthusiastic about
the application actually so um i i i
would speak in favor of um
uh agreeing officer's recommendation to
grant here uh i think it's a really
exciting opportunity for armstrong it's
a real chance to to regenerate that that
site that's a brownfield site and i
think it it could be a great addition to
to um turn center and it's got
appropriate ten center uses within it um
which uh you know i agree with
councillor welton on this you you don't
necessarily have to have to drive to i'm
so i'm not i'm not concerned so much
about the parking i recognize that
residents might have concerns and
and
that that is a very busy sort of
congested area in the in the middle of
ermston
um
but
you know longer term we're aspiring
firms and to be an active neighborhood
and um
you know there is a big car park in eden
square there is parking in ermeston but
if if if it's still a problem then you
know i agree with councillor welton
that's that's something separate to to
address but actually i think you know
the
the long-term vision that we have is
frozen to be an active neighborhood and
and this this development could play a
key part in that you know i love the
idea of people walking and cycling to
this and you know having rows and rows
of cycling racks so people people can
get there in in a you know environmental
uh environmentally friendly and an
active way so i'm not so concerned about
about the parking um
i think
you know the environmental credentials
of the building are decent they could be
better i think um
and
i do yeah i do think it's not it's not
the prettiest building i've seen
definitely uh i think it might
i'm hoping it will look better in
reality particularly with the green
walls but i know one of the objections
described it as a as a you know
shipping containers that have been
dropped on the site and i can i can
understand where they're coming from but
actually i welcome
you know what mr carr said that you know
this new application
has been adapted to provide more open
space and and to you know future future
proof the development
against more restrictions because of the
pandemic and you know i think that's
quite insightful um to do that um
there's good accessibility within
development as well because of the open
space so i think that's good
my main concern is about the accessible
parking um
so
you know there's
funding for the tro to provide one space
which wouldn't be dedicated to this
development and
i think that was a value-add i don't
think that was part of the original
proposal
and
given the openness of the site i think
it would have been possible to provide
some accessible parking on-site um
so that
that is my main concern uh about this
but there is
there is parking nearby um
mainly eden square and i think that is
24-hour parking so i'm just
thinking of hotel guest business guests
who'll be using that that part of the
development
so i think maybe that lack of accessible
parking is is quite a
maybe a more
weighty adverse impact than than
suggested in the report but it is
considered as an adverse impact
uh in the report and i think the
you know the benefits of the scheme do
do far outweigh that adverse impact so
uh i'll be happy to support the officer
recommendation on this one thank you
thank you um councilman morgan
uh thank you chair um
i think i'm probably gonna agree with
council hartley more than councillor
bunting about the beauty of it but um i
think um
i think it's definitely in the eye of
the beholder um and uh i can certainly
imagine someone would have a very
different view to me on that i'm really
positive about this about the
regenerative possibilities it holds
um and i don't actually have an issue in
terms of parking regarding either the
hospitality or the office pods um these
aren't large scale officers and i have
to agree with councillor wealth and
encounter hartley that we can't reduce
dependency on the car if we build a
multi-story car park every time we have
a development like this
um but i do think there's nowhere near
enough um disabled spaces
the one big concern though i have about
is about hotel parking so where are we
expecting these guests to come from so i
if you just mentioned city centre i
imagine most of the guests would expect
not to drive
now i know ultra can better um in terms
of where we've got two big hotels and
where do most
how do most of the guests get to
ultraman if they're going to
to the football um they come by car and
then get public transport into the city
center or old trafford or wherever
and i have to be honest i can't imagine
that's gonna be any different to norms
um
so i really do have big concerns about
hotel parking having said that i'm
probably still tending to um likely to
vote it's in favor but i really i'm
interested to hear
other members views thank you
thank you um councillor hassan
thank
you first of all i am fully sporting
this application so number one and why
amsterdam is a very vibrant
and thriving and
town center
and
at this development will definitely
hence and
the local economy
and of course the hurdle
it means the employment
the employment comes means it will
increase the revenue for the local local
people
and it will increase the
circle flow of money within the economy
with a local economy
and
only one issue which is the other
my colleagues are
raising is
working
tell me one town center in the country
uh i'm fully agreed my
very senior colleague counselor david
eckton
yeah there's no parking issue
any any parking issues everywhere but we
need to to address this issue otherwise
if you we look at the features of this
uh planning it is a wonderful
and uh
amsterdam needs this kind of development
for the future
of the local economy to be honest i
fully support this
thank you um counselor chalking
thanks jeff um
do you like it
um
but i will sh i i i really do welcome
all the recommendations by the way in
the uh and the officers report to the
terms of the restrictions the opening
hours operating hours etc there's a lot
of thought that's got into that
um but i do echo council hartley and
morgan's comments with the
um
accessibility of the site you know
there's because when i looked at it
there's a real concern for me
that it is a business center it is a
hotel or it's going to be um
and there isn't enough disabled parking
uh you know we have issues where i live
with people coming to work who do need
access to to work to their workplace
but they need to have you know less than
200 metres of access so
because of their disabilities and that
just isn't enough here so that's i'm i
really do want to support this but i'm
kind of sitting on the defensive on the
side as well saying that it's not quite
there yet
um and i don't really know
where we can go with that
uh if there's any more that could be
done on it um
that's where i'm sitting on that
thank you um councillor dagnol
um
well broadly speaking i support it i'm
not utterly offended by this look of the
building like some of my colleagues um
i don't have an issue generally speaking
with parking by the public i have just a
slight concern about the
vehicle access for all deliveries from
railway road
and how that will develop in the future
so there just seems to be some sort of
access from the road at the back from
greenfield road and my concern would be
that looks to me to be quite a
residential road actually
as time goes by that that will be used
for access for deliveries and also if
you are talking about having
markets with different you know with
different themes that also means
different stall holders come in perhaps
on a daily or weekend basis they will
want to arrive early to set up the
stalls and they may well want to leave
while the street is still quite busy as
the end of the market approaches
especially in the winter so i do have
some concerns about in the future
whether the access from the greenfield
road will not just be used for
emergencies but actually will be used
for
stall holders and for deliveries um
which seems to be a bit of a struggle
if you were setting up a market
expecting maybe 10 15 20 stall holders
all to arrive at the same time in the
morning i think that that might be an
issue at the front of
the hole as is suggested in the papers
but
i think maybe all teething problems that
might be knocked out i don't know
thank you um
i know a number of members have
indicated they'd like to come back into
the discussion i will just call members
who haven't spoken first though um
counsel and minis
thank you chair um
obviously it's a it's a bit ugly but you
know that's that's not our thing to
comment on massively is it it's not a
thing to say no for um i like a lot of
it um i like the thought that's gone
into
um
into it in terms of like you know to its
resilience to that to
cavite and and lockdowns
and so therefore the employment will
continue and people aren't going to be
stuck at home with no jobs or etcetera
so i think there's a lot there's a lot
to be liked um
my one bug bear i mean it's the parking
and i don't mean the parking for
everyone to encourage people to to be
driving to it i mean
for the for the for the disabled spaces
and i feel like what what you know in a
if you look at an ideal world you want
spaces for disabled skills park and you
want lots of places for bikes to be able
to be locked up so people can if you
just imagine what people will do there
as it were
um
it doesn't quite do that
um i don't know if that can we can we
put a condition of
cut that's a question i guess for you
guys can we put a condition of how many
disabled spaces to be put in is that is
that no no
is it just
um
there is no parking um suggested on site
at all so there's a disabled space sorry
no it's on street
okay okay
so yeah so there's there's nothing there
until um
that's the part that that says no to me
um because if you're gonna make
something that's a multi-use facility um
you're
ruling
people out from it and excluding people
and so that's going to be my my bit that
says no i'm afraid thank you
thank you and councillor maitland
thanks chair um no one's mentioned the
railway
and the railway station that we've got
in ermeston so that's my i'm sort of
parking really for some for some of the
issues
um and we have got quite a lot of
parking in amsterdam as well it's not
just the main there's um parking down
asheville road is ashfield at the back
of
cheeky cherubs
uh yeah that is uh
there's a few small parts
of the areas as well but the station to
me the railway is maybe an answer as
well one thing i would like to ask is
why a hotel
has there been some research as to
the necessity of a hotel
proposals and i just thought i've have
they come up with some you know numbers
to say yeah people want that sort of
thing is there an answer okay we can see
if there's an answer
yeah there's a question we asked the
applicants as well and the answer that
we got back from them was that what
they're trying to provide is a hub so
it's a business hub and with boardrooms
and meeting spaces and then spaces for
people to to stay over for business
meetings and and that sort of facility
so it's a it's a it's a hub that
provides all facilities for people to
eat drink have a meeting and then stay
over that that was the applicant's
response to that
i have a very quick answer of this
question as well
uh maybe that planet has a plan for
future
the
because hotel rooms are very expensive
in the town center and and the railway
station is there on the walking distance
and then they can catch the train and go
towards the town center so it may be the
reason this is what i think
thank you um i i suppose i would just
echo what councilman maitland has said
there and perhaps longer serving members
of the committee will know that i've
quite happily proposed and turned down
applications before for um
developments that have included hotel
provision where i felt that the lack of
parking for vision has been a real
concern but the key issue for me is
whether or not
the site is a sustainable site so
places where i i've supported refusing
permission because of lack of parking
provision i've done so because i felt
that it's not reasonable to accept
expect people to um gain access to that
location except for the use of that car
but the key point here i think is in
paragraph 94 which is that this is a
town center location well serviced by an
existing public transport infrastructure
it's got a good um bus route it's got a
train station with direct access into
manchester and to liverpool and as
councillors maitland has also indicated
there is parking provision elsewhere um
now i i appreciate and i welcome the the
attention that committee committee's
given to accessible parking i think
it speaks volumes about the sort of
concern you have when you're making
determinations on planet applications i
suppose what i'd say is you know there
are previous developments that were
proposed that had no parking provision
whatsoever and
the applicant
who's brought forward this proposed
development similarly did not
propose to incorporate any sort of
accessible parking provision and it's
only for the work of our planning
service that um a provision has been
made for off-site accessible parking and
i think we should welcome that really i
accept that it's only one parking bay
but i think
it's an incremental game so so i do
welcome that well apart from that i'd
also like to agree with um some of the
comments made by mr carr and also by
councillor hartley um in that you know
this is actually an exciting opportunity
for instant i think mr carr was right
that there's very similar provision in
terms of um
uh
retail and hospitality offer in other
parts of the butler and i think well if
you can enjoy that offer in altering
them
why shouldn't you be able to enjoy it in
amsterdam homestead is a rapidly
changing community it's changed very
quickly even in in
my living memory of it and i think you
know it's going to become a hot spot for
people to go out and socialize with
friends and family and i think this will
be an ideal location for them so to do
so i i'm happy to support the
application before us tonight uh i think
it's been proposed by council of
attorney
i'll second the uh we support granting
permission
i did ask to speak before we go to the
vote
okay thanks um i think what
members
should recognize around that area that
there was a thriving market
in ermstan
on that site
with
lots of stalls
um
many more than what they that there are
now there's no car parking spaces
whatsoever
it's all roads if you you know if
you're coming by car
and
and remember also that
and a lot of you know disabled people
did go but they part on the road with
their badges and you know you have to
remember that fact as well
so i i think it is a town center
uh i think it does need regenerating
further it has had you know um money
spent on it
particularly around
eden square but i think
that
corner of ernst town center is crying
out for that kind of development so
for me
um
yeah i i don't think the buildings are
as bad as what people are actually
saying quite frankly um but it is all
about taste that but
for me it is the regeneration that i'm
um
keen to actually see in ernst
thank you councillor and that that point
you make about the blue badge parking
provision scheme is acknowledged in the
report as well at paragraph 104 um
i did have councillor bunting and
councillor thomas i think wanting to
come back into the discussion um
councillor thomas
thank you jeff how are you looking at
council blunty when you said my name
i'd just like to reiterate that at the
very beginning i said i'm not
particularly against this screen but i'm
not particularly for it
the
the look of the building does not sit in
any way with any of the streets in the
area
you have terraced houses to its left you
have
set back so many tax houses along
further on the way
in regards to the parking
people that will use the market are
local people and those local people are
already in amsterdam at this moment in
time
the parking is full
from those people
the hub and the hotel are designed to
bring people in from outside and we all
around this table would love it if
everybody got on the train or got on the
bus to go to business meetings it's not
feasible it's not doesn't happen
okay you have the artisan market every
four weeks in urban and the chaos that
that brings is absolute chaos
more mooreside road everywhere it's
dangerous okay that's my point about the
parking all the parking that has been
mentioned even square
um
down atkinson road the private one on
the back of the parade
flixton road
golden hill park when it's open
every weekend is chock-full
chock-a-full that's without
a hotel
and a business hub
businesses in urban have proper have
premises
business within ernst and within the um
fall of m41 are not going to use a
business over extra expense certainly
not at this time coming through a
pandemic
might the the the market on the floor is
a lot smaller and i agree with
councillor acton at one one time i used
to use arms to market all the time there
used to be hundreds of support stalls
the reason it's not there anymore is
there wasn't
it died as markets
everywhere died
you know stockport market and berry
market the only markets that are
sustainable shall we say i don't think
it's sustainable because i don't think
in the ermeston or the trafford area
you're going to draw people into this
look at the building is the look of the
building but i think it's more attuned
than the residents of emerson are more
attuned to the original m41 food hall
which gave a more vibrant and local feel
to it herbstone is not a destination
people come to instead and move on
elsewhere on a so whether it be socially
or otherwise that's what i'm concerned
about not particularly it being
developed i think it's
it's long overdue being developed
and we know it's long overdue because we
got planning permission very many years
ago
nothing's happened on it
i'm concerned that this is designed this
way to not undermine the bottom floor of
the market but it's a way of making
money
rather than having a market that you can
only lease out my concern is that it's
not feasible
thank you um councillor bunting
thank you chairman it's uh once again
difficult to disagree with us who said
before me so a lot of the things i was
going to point out have always just been
said so i won't repeat them just to
point out a few things i know we keep
talking about the lockdown and this is
to be a wonderful thing during the
pandemic that will be a relatively short
term thing this
monstrosity is going to be with us long
after we've all forgotten about covid19
uh
at least until somebody comes along with
a further planning application to level
it and put something worthwhile in its
place in terms of the parking uh and we
keep talking about there's lots of other
parking in the air room we've mentioned
eden square that is a shoppers car park
i remember very very well the
application going through
council hartley i'm sitting there you're
sitting at the time uh the purpose of
that car park is to make make it so that
the other businesses in amsterdam
surrounding in that eden square and on
the on the main drag have a parking
facility and it's that which is keeping
it one of the reasons why it's been it
was regenerated and it's been it is a
vibrant area now if we fill that uh
shoppers car park as it was called up
with people from uh cars from the hotel
and traders were there all day because
they've brought their stuff to trade and
then gone over the road and parked their
car so you can't get into the shoppers
car park anymore that is going to damage
the whole of um not just this area so
that is a point or something people keep
referring to it as that and yes we've
had previous applications some of them
better than this application just
because this is one
uh use for this site and yes it needs
regenerating does not mean that this is
the
the ideal solution i think we're in
danger of falling into a politician's
trap yeah some something must be done
this is something let's do this that is
of course if we do actually go ahead
with this one all the previous
applications we've already passed have
never gone ahead so let's see if this if
it does get voted through actually
happens hopefully not
thank you councillor um
motion has been proposed in second did
the
permission be granted for this
application in line with office of
recommendation before we turn to the
vote i just want to make sure that
there's nobody
who wants to
make a contribution who hasn't had the
opportunity to do so
now
we have a quite a lengthy discussion so
we'll move to the voter
members who are happy to support the
motion the
permission be granted the development
can indicate now
okay and those uh not supporting that
motion
yeah okay um that motion is carried and
permission is
granted thank you
um we'll now turn to application 105 662
which is a 119 park road in timperley
which is on page 77 of the committee
report
um just wait for
um speakers to join us in the boom and
then we'll receive an introduction from
mslos
nice
um so before we hear from speakers this
application 119 park road will be
introduced by muslows from the planning
department
thank you chair the application relates
to um the site of 119 park road in
timperley
and the application sorry the
application site is currently occupied
by an early 20th century building
towards the front of the site which is
occupied by gp's practice and a detached
bungalow to the rear of the site
both properties share an existing access
from park road with parking for the gps
practice to the front and rear of the
building
some photographs of the existing
building
which is recognized as a non-designated
heritage asset and with historical and
architectural significance
planning permission is sought for the
conversion of the existing gp practice
to create one family dwelling with the
gpu practice relocated into templey
village to a purpose-built library and
gp center along with the erection of
four town houses to the rear following
the demolition of the existing bungalow
at 119 a park road
the pero's new build properties are
are to be saved by the existing access
off park road here and a new separate
access will be
created to serve the proposed detached
dwelling
the new dwellings would have a
contemporary style with a traditional
form and materials and are considered to
be
of an approach considered to be
attractive and appropriate to their
setting
the conversion of the existing building
is considered to be sensitive to the
building's historic and architectural
significance with a little change to the
existing elevational treatments of the
building nutritable harm is caused to
the setting of the non-designated
heritage asset through the erection of
the new dwellings within its grounds and
the loss of part of the traditional
stone wall to the front of the building
nevertheless this is considered to be
outweighed by the significant benefits
of the retention of the building
each of the new build properties will
have access to two car parking spaces to
the front of each property and a further
four car parking spaces will be provided
in a communal parking area the proposed
new access and parking arrangements um
for the converted property are
accessible
balancing the car parking provision with
the ratio of hard to soft lands the
gaping and the impact on the setting of
the non-designated
heritage asset along with the
accessibility of the site is considered
to make the car parking provision
accessible
acceptable
the proposals have been amended during
the consideration of the application to
improve the external appearance of the
new build properties including the
reduction of these rio dormers
and landscaping to the site and to
improve amenity impacts
objections have been received in
relation to the impact on residential
amenity landscaping highways character
scale and design and a letter of support
has been received in relation to the
positive impact the development would
have on the local area through the
renovation of the existing building and
the positive use of the site
the proposal is considered considered
acceptable in principle resulting in a
small contribution to the borough's
housing land supply in a sustainable
location and the retention of the
designated non-designated heritage asset
the proposal is considered to comply
with the development plan as a whole
and the tilted balance is engaged
however the adverse impacts would not
significantly or demonstrably outweigh
the benefits
as such the application is recommended
for approval
and subject to conditions
thank you ms lowe's um we have two
speakers to this application speaking
against is mr harvey
hi
hi mr harvey thanks for joining us um
you have three minutes to speak if you
do run over time i'll just politely ask
that you wrap up your contribution and
before you begin can you just make sure
the microphone's sort of illuminated so
that we can hear you
[Music]
yeah
all right we're illuminating could
everyone hear me is that okay
uh yeah so i'll uh hopefully we'll be
less than three minutes so uh on behalf
of the residents of ennerdale and
aiksville road who've made the
contributions during the planning
application pro process
i would like to reassure the members of
the planning committee that we support
the residential development of 119 part
road
and associated gardens but not the
proposed plan
whilst we we acknowledge the revised
plans gone go some way to satisfying our
concerns regarding privacy light and
close proximity
the proposed construction of four number
three story town houses
falls short of satisfying the
requirements for a tandem and back land
development
supplementary housing guidance under
paragraph 2.5 recognizes that such
developments cause issues with
neighboring properties being overlooked
additionally under paragraph 10.2 the
guidance state building on an infill
site that is taller than nearby
properties may be over dominant and out
of place
it is therefore advisable to consider
providing houses of similar heights to
those
nearby we note the planning officer's
comments justifying the three-story
development and also note an important
omission
what is omitted from the planning
offices report are the distance between
the two referred to
properties
uh one two one part road and one one
nine part road
these are currently sit 15 meters set
back
which is one two one part road from the
properties on akersfield road and 80
meters set back to the property on 119
park road
we believe justifying the development of
four number properties with a 9.3 meter
roof line making reference to the making
reference to the height of 119 and one
two one part road fails the height test
alluded to under paragraph 10.2
of spg-1
these newly developed properties will
sit circa 33 meters away from those on
acresville road not 80 meters as they
were originally built
as this is the case with the original
dwelling on park road
the planning officer's report correctly
draws attention to issues connected to
plot 1 and plot two
both these developments fail to meet the
property separation requirements under
pg-1
and directly impact number eight
emmerdale 28 30 and 32 a clear road
whilst we understand the commercial
driver for the developer to maximize his
or her return the proposed development
of three-story townhouses is not
appropriate for such a backland
development
thank you
thank you mr harvey um
speaking in favor of the application i
think it's mr hansen
hi mr hanson if you're okay to sit where
mr harvey presently is and similarly you
have three minutes to speak if you do
run over time i'll just politely ask
that you wrap up your country thank you
can you hear me
cheers
first thank you for the opportunity to
speak in today and on behalf of favor of
the application
as clarified in the plan officers
committee report the development at 119
park road and the wider site is a unique
opportunity to provide high quality
residential family dwellings in a
sustainable housing location the new
build 2.5 storey homes proposed to the
rear of the site provide generous living
accommodation to the ground floor with
large bifold windows onto the garden the
upper floors provide four number
bedrooms a family bathroom an ensuite to
the master bedroom and a study the
houses have been designed around
principles of a modern family home
including a separate workspace bathroom
facilities on each floor spacious
bedrooms and a utility to the ground
floor these are all desirable spaces
that we see so many houses in the area
now extending to achieve
a valuable part of the development seeks
to sensitively renovate a local
designated heritage asset by renovating
the property into a large family
dwelling this will ensure the property
continues to contribute to the visual
amenity and character of the local area
for years to come
the office offices report acknowledges
all properties are provided with
adequate immunity areas car parking
space and space motorcycle storage
overall the design is considered to be
attractive and appropriate for its
setting
the developer has taken the project and
the feelings of excite the science
neighbors seriously a detailed and
extensive pre-application was undertaken
with traffic council with whom we
discussed various layouts a lot of
discussion were driven by the minimizing
the impact on the local community and
ensuring we provide the most appropriate
amount of development for the site and
to enable the retention and renovation
of the existing building
without requirement pic homes organized
a community consultation writing to the
site's neighbors inviting them to attend
and review the proposals prior to a full
application
we spent considerable time explaining
the scheme to each and every person we
took on both their comments we amended
the design we introduced measures to
reduce the impact of the development
however it is apparent from the number
of objections we did not manage to
satisfy all of the neighbors concerns at
our first attempt we acknowledge this
and during the determining the
determination period we work closely
with the planning officer to further
revise the proposals in order to
minimise the scheme and impact on the
local residents
the issues and resolutions made within
the designs are as follows
the height
as mentioned the proposed new dwellings
have been significantly reduced in
height the scale of the rear doma has
also been reduced we have now lost a uh
we have now lost a second floor bedroom
which has now become a home study
landscaping we listen to the objections
and respond from the council consultees
making changes to the bin store
locations providing acoustic close
boarded fencing to the rear of 600 dale
drive to minimise the impact of the cars
into the car park
overshadowing our neighbours we have
reduced the height of the buildings and
conducted a solar assessment of the
development which was included within
our design access statement the exercise
illustrates only part of number eight
enderdale drive's garden is effective
for a short period of the day there is
no overshadowing at all to xfield drive
during the determination period we move
the proposed houses forward to help
further minimize any overshadowing
and we agree with the planning officer
that the form scale of the development
of the forum houses provides a
transition between the homes on any dail
drive in akersfield road and the
properties along with hanson you have
run over time so if you can just quickly
wrap up that's right no thank you um
pic homes has made significant
amendments to the design to alleviate
the objectives concerns we have worked
very closely with the lpa in order to
deliver a design that was within policy
and enhances the visual immunity of the
area
thank you very much thank you thanks for
being here tonight um are there any
members looking to open the discussion
council at diagonal
um broadly speaking i support this
development the houses look very similar
to ones built reasonably recently in
christchurch grounds
not far away a few hundred yards away
from where this is proposed i think the
use of the black garden to accommodate
homes is entirely appropriate um we do
live in a very high density suburban
area
and as mentioned
providing housing for large families um
is a challenge to us
and so i welcome this development i feel
it
particularly with the preservation of
the current house which is absolutely
beautiful so i'm really pleased that
that's going to be kept
um it does seem slightly to me to be
slightly over developed for the amount
of land but if
people want to live in the area and are
prepared to put up with such um close
neighbours then
good luck to them that's all i can think
so i'm broadly in favor of it
thank you and councillor bunting
thank you chairman yeah i'm
reasonably in favor of this application
i think the design sort of is a is a
good design
certainly a lot better than the last one
um and um
i think it fits in well sorry forgive
that slightly flippant comment gentlemen
uh it's uh if i think this design fits
in um in in well in in the area that
it's uh
to be located the main objections from
from the existing residents in is in
terms of overlooking and we've seen the
obviously the developers sort of as
engaged in consultation and reduced the
height
and the size of the dormers which
although they're still quite large and
not particularly aesthetic i think are
no longer maybe the problem that they
may have been initially
uh yes they've reduced uh or they claim
to have reduced it by one bedroom and
made a home office but that's slightly
disingenuous it just means crossing out
you all you have to do is take the desk
out of the home office put the bedroom
put the bed back in and suddenly the
room has converted back to the bedroom
so i've seen that on various
applications where they put oh yes we're
having three bedrooms and a home office
that it's four bedrooms
but that said i don't have an objection
to that um so
also again given the
distances that we're talking i think the
distances whilst they're not the
very large separation distance that was
there previously
from the original house to the to the
rear of the uh cartilage they are still
more than sufficient i feel so whilst i
can sympathize with the residents and i
understand that um
i understand that they're not happy uh i
think that this is gonna cause nowhere
near the issue that they perhaps uh
believe it to initially and give it a
short while and i think they'll get more
than used to them
i don't think councillor doug neal did
you make a proposal
in that case chairman i will propose
that we accept officer recommendation uh
and grant the application thank you
chairman thank you councillor minis
thank you
chair i know this site very well and so
i'm a typically counsellor and
i know the the doctor surgery building i
know it's inside out because it was my
doctor's um
there so
i the parts i really really like about
this application are the the um
the restoration of
of the doctor's surgery in my mind as it
were
is really really nice so i think that
and i really really like to applaud
really the the developer on
on their
um what they're going to do with the
building because it does require
a lot of tlc um
so that's that's a lovely thing
i
do have i share
the residents concerns nearby residents
concerns with the height of the building
and the buildings at the back um
i think that the
alterations that have been made
um are to reduce the height
do goes a lot a large way towards making
them more
more acceptable the houses themselves
the four houses are going to be really
really they are close together
if you if you all know the site well um
at the back they are going to be close
together but that's the choice of the
people who live there whether they want
to be that close to that store neighbor
and luckily they're not
that far the thing is i think that
everyone is used to in this area of the
old doctor surgery building being there
and obviously there's that the the owner
used to live in the bungalow at the back
that's going to get demolished
so
and next door to it at one time is the
community center which i'm sure
will feature later in
in our
in our time um
that's where the library so the library
in the village moved next to the next
door building the community centre
and then when development in the in
timperley village is
all ready and everybody's moving back
the ideas library goes back to where it
was but in the albeit a new building and
the doctors are moving
and there so that's how this has all
come about because the owner of this
site wanted to want to then sell the
sites that's how this if everybody gets
out what i mean
i think there's a there's it's not
perfect it's clearly not perfect and
it's not satisfied all right all the
nearby residents and
but i don't
and you know and i'm hoping that
obviously because adults said that
they're happy to go back and try to
um you know get get more get it to be
closer to what everybody the nearby
residents and i really really like that
actually i mean it's very rare we see a
developer saying they're willing to try
and work with residents to try and
to try and satisfy everybody i think
once we get used to it being there
i think
we'll be okay i didn't particularly like
personally didn't like the look of the
ones on acres field although the new
houses that appeared on akersfield
they're in my mind
monstrosities and they're enormous i
don't know if anyone else knows the
where i'm talking about but
yeah just from the side with holy cross
so just by there i'm i don't like i
think these look better than those and
you know not then obviously eyes
beholder and all but you know
they're not perfect yes but i think that
in planning grounds i can't really say
no to them
and i do
i like at least the attitude of the
developer and i think like what they've
tried to do here
you know i could have landed with
somebody else that would have done
something awful like truly awful
so i think we'll all we simply folk
we're gonna have to
i think learn to live with it so
i hope that makes sense i thought i'd
try to give some context because i know
i know the the area very well thank you
thank you councillor councillor thomas
thank you chairman thank you councilman
for the tour of award and history in the
background
much appreciated
um
only i'll be very brief chair um
my concern was the proximity of the the
four houses at the back but when when
you look the houses that are behind
there and on a dale they have to then
their immediate neighbors left and right
similar uh
spaces so i'm more than happy to second
the motion to
accept officers recommendation
thank you councillor akanola
um i'm happy to support this scheme and
to me it's not it's a good use of the
space it's nothing
unusual in terms of proximity to
neighbours when you consider the wards
like clifford where you're in terraced
houses so i think these four quite large
areas don't sit too
large in that area um
and i think if this had been in trafford
they probably tried to plunk a 10 foot
block of flats in that same space so i
think we've got off
lightly thank you and councillor morgan
um thank you chair um yeah i'm ready to
support these i do get the objections um
the residents have been used to a
relatively open space effectively um and
is is a
relatively high density in comparison to
what some of the
the
post-war houses which are nearby and
into all houses
and i do get they are just a slightly
bit taller but fundamentally they are
taller um and
the the dormers are
dramatic i actually quite like them and
i think it was councillor dagnalls
referred to um and council ministers
talked about the fact there are similar
houses i actually was thinking
there's there's a in a different part of
him playing not in simply ward um which
i walk past to get to my um's nursery
there's similar houses again it was a
bungalow and it's got three three
similar houses and it is you know it is
dramatic but i do think you get used to
it um um i do really understand the
resident's concern and i really do
hope that given the fact that the
distances i think as council thomas said
are i think reasonable um within the
gardens i think um
once the development is up i do think
that they will um fit in um in a mixture
that um has worked in similar locations
so thank you chad
thank you councillor hartley
i didn't
sorry in here thank you chair um
yeah i'm i'm supportive of the
application but not without some
reservations actually i have to say i
think i think the design of the house is
the new houses at the rear is is good
the blue high quality i think the
landscaping
um on the wider side looks good i think
it's probably still too much hard
standing but i know it has been reduced
already
i'm less keen on the dormers but except
that
they look like that because the size of
the rear domes has been reduced
um
my reservations are the height um
so
they are taller than the surrounding
houses and
i i i sort of don't like that trend it's
a trend because you know it's two and a
half three-story houses um but you do
see a lot of a lot of houses around
traffic new developments that are
noticeably taller than neighboring
houses and they do look out of place but
i think here the uh i think the height
is lower than
119 isn't it um so i think because of
this particular location it's probably
all right i think if those houses we're
not um
we're not sup behind the old doctor
surgery then i i don't think the height
would be acceptable um personally um
so i'm broadly spotted i did have one
query actually which was around
paragraphs 53 and 54 in the report
um refer to the um
the uh
the lha recommending a condition for
four cycle parking spaces
uh shakur parking spaces uh
but i couldn't see a condition that
covers that in the schedule i might be
wrong so i wasn't clear whether
that recommendation wasn't accepted or
the condition had just been omitted
unless i've missed it
thank you
i'm sure we could get some clarification
for that but before then councillor
welton indicated
thanks chair um yeah our echo council is
concerned with the amount of hard
standing in this in this proposal um it
is actually a reasonably sustainable
location it's not far from the tram it's
not that far from timperley village
um
yet we've
there's four
there's each house each of the new build
houses has two car parking spaces
outside the front yet
they've we've
allowed them to take another chunk of
car parking spaces you know for
additional car parking spaces and
basically saying saying okay yeah let's
have a three-car household on one of the
most congested roads
in in trafford park road is awful and we
should be doing everything that we can
to encourage people to have the minimum
number of cars
you know that their lifestyle
will permit and just by giving
extra car parking spaces we're literally
encouraging people to have more cars and
that's exactly what this area of tempe
does not need
thank you councillor welton um
just before we uh received feedback
about the condition that councilor
hartley referred to i did just want to
reflect on
the contribution made by mr harvey
because he did indicate i think
he made specific reference to
the distance between 119 and one two one
park road
as well as um reference to
spg one and i think failure of paragraph
2.5 and 10.2 um
if my reading of the report is correct
the officer report i think that that's
addressed in paragraphs 23 through 25
and it
as as i've read it is acknowledged that
there's been a breach that i was just
wondering if you could talk us through
that so that members
can
keep it in mind when they're making a
decision given mr harvey's a
presentation thank you
yes um council hartley on your query and
there is sheds shown in each of the rear
gardens on the um site plan so as part
of the plans condition we would be um
they would have to provide those sheds
as part of that so whilst there's not a
specific cycle parking condition the
storage areas are shown on the site plan
um okay yes in regards to the distances
yes the report does um identify that
there is a shortfall and for plots one
and two in regards to the distance to
the rear boundary and from the dormers
the second floor
and there is a shortfall there that's
identified and what we've done and what
the report says is that there would be a
condition to obscure glaze and the the
windows within those two dormers and to
ensure that there wasn't any overlooking
because of the breach there that's been
updated um in condition
14 i want to say in the um in the air
and so so that's that's included now and
that would um alleviate any overlooking
from that breach in the in the distances
but all other distances comply and
there's the the rear gardens on acres
field road there's a length of a minimum
of 20 meters into the rear boundary of
the site and then the um the separation
distances from the proposed dwellings to
the boundaries of plots to three and
four then comply and so there is a small
breach there but we we feel we can and
it's acceptable due to the condition for
the obscure glazing
[Music]
thank you i suppose
i think i'm probably in agreement with
most members that
probably just echo the contribution that
council hartley made around slight
frustration about the height differences
between the properties and those that
are already
on site in the surrounding area um so it
was proposed by councillor bunting and
seconded i think by councillor thomas
that um
this application be granted permission
fidget development is there any member
who hasn't spoken who would like to
speak
this evening
nope okay um we'll move to the vote then
um
members happy to support the motion the
permission be granted for development in
line with officer recommendation can
indicate now
okay that motion is carried and the
permission is granted um thank you
everybody
our speakers for attending um the next
application for consideration this
evening is one zero five five four zero
ninety five derwent road in flixton
which is on page 68 with the committee
report
um
this application is going to be
introduced by mr day
just clarify
do we have speakers
good
um
okay thank you um
application
10544095 derwent road the application's
now going to be introduced by mr dave
from the planning service
yeah thank you chair um
as reported in the additional
information report um it's come to the
attention of officers that the site
location plan
submitted with this application
uh shows a different site boundary from
that shown on a copy of the land
registry plan also submitted by the
applicant during the course of the
application
and a different boundary from those from
the boundaries shown on other recent
applications relating to the property
certificate a has been submitted with
the application confirming that the
applicant is the sole owner of the land
to which the application relates
however having regard to these
discrepancies it is considered that
further investigation and discussion
with the applicant is required
in order to clarify whether the reddit
site boundary and the ownership
certificate are in fact correct
it's therefore recommended that this
application is deferred in order to
allow this matter to be investigated
further
committee members understand what's
being asked of them there i think it's
explained in the air
um that essentially there is some
confusion around land ownership
and as such we've been asked not to make
a determination on the application and
rather defer it to a later meeting
whilst that's explored and determined so
anyone who monster counsellor
thomas
thank you chad i'm very uncomfortable
with it being deferred because
at this present time outside of the
actual plans are submitted that we want
to defer
there has been buildings going on
that is
obtrusive to every single neighbor
on the property
i visited the site yesterday
i couldn't get access to 95 due and
there was nobody home
but i did visit uh
aldermere crescent
and went into the back garden and i got
five meters away from
the
breeze block wall that is 10 centimeters
away from
this um
residence
fence
and i couldn't see the houses on the
other side of the wall all i could see
was sky it's imposing that much it is
unbelievable that this was even minded
to grant let alone be deferred
there is a gym and an art studio
and a toilet and shower with a kitchen
again in here this is a residential
property that is being put forward in my
opinion
and the size of it itself
because at the moment is breeze blocked
with no roof on it's going to be a flat
roof it will be about two two meters
nine by my estimations from the uh
garden of the house i was in yesterday
and it just
impacts
horrendously on every garden around it
and not one of the neighbors in that
area support it and i think all of them
to to a house have
put a massive
objection into this
playing
on basically on on the condition that is
so high
is far outstrips the plans that were
there it is
30 centimeters from the garden
boundaries on the left and right of the
the building and 130 millimeters from a
fence at the house i was in yesterday
in the planet he said that the walls are
going to be
um whitewashed
i failed to see how the white wash could
be put on the rear wall
uh we're backing onto overdale crescent
sorry aldermere crescent because there's
no room for a paintbrush let alone a
person to get down and paint it uh i
would i would bring a motion that we
don't defer an emotion that we would
refuse application this application
tonight
thank you
bunting were you indicating earlier
um i was going to but not now i've just
heard what i've just heard um
it's
what my initial argument was in fact if
it's a valid procedural reason to go
ahead and do this i did try and visit
the site i
couldn't get into it there was no one
present when i went there but i didn't
go and go around was it wasn't able to
go on the back
so i haven't seen the actual all i've
seen is the actual front sight um
[Music]
and i was i got the email
i was gonna try and go and i got the
email telling you that it's going to be
most likely there's going to be a
suggestion of deferral and i thought um
and i was going to say i agree with that
and now something in the condo is to i
think i i'm still edging towards the
argument that if the officers need it to
defer for valid procedural reasons and
we have little no choice i've never
known as refused that request from an
officer in the what
17 years
or so that i've been doing this
committee i've never known his refusal
request for officer to defer there's a
valid procedural reason so to do
but then again i'm i've hear what
counsel thomas has to say and i don't
doubt your word for one moment in terms
of that
so
as i'm saying so as i'm saying i'm
not sure because the best course of
action i think though
on on balance it may be necessary to
despite council thomas's
uh representation to go along with the
officers and
acquiesce to their request as we have
always done in the past yeah and uh
understood counsellor thank you the
committee doesn't often get
recommendations for deferrable um and
i'm i suppose my concern is that if
we don't accept the recommendation
and there's a valid reason for officers
to be suggesting a differable it could
ultimately compromise the planning
process further down the line and i'm
just wondering if perhaps there's some
clarification that can explain to
members if there's consequences
to refusing to differ
yes thank you chairman um if
if it is found that the ownership
certificate has be and the
site location plan
is incorrect and officers do have a
reason to believe that it is
we've done due diligence
and we've advised the committee of that
and the committee choose to not take
that advice then
there is a strong likelihood any
decision could be found to be unlawful
thank you that's that that's a helpful
qualification
um counselor hunting
on that basis chairman that confirms
that we thought previously i'll help us
move things along and propose we accept
officer recommendation and reluctantly
defer uh i don't think we have any
choice given the circumstance
thank you councillor acton what are you
indicating yeah it was just to support
everything that my colleague has
said
and that that is exactly my feelings
but i think we have to take you know the
advice that we've received and
it would maybe create more problems that
we want
but i think it
it would have been
if it was possible to have um
voted on this because all it does is
prolong the agony of many of the
residents in that area
but i i i do accept the kind of legal
advice
thank you councillor hartley
yeah i i think we should defer for
because of the advice that we've just
had from officers
i i mean it it maybe officers can't say
more about it but
uh you know we do see applications where
we're told the ownership isn't relevant
if somebody wants to apply for planning
permission over landed and they can so
but i'm
suspecting there's more to it than that
um and if the advice is that you know we
would be
susceptible to a legal challenge i would
accept that um we should we should defer
i i hear what council thomas is saying
about about the building that's going on
there at the moment um and so the
referral
obviously will prolong that but i
suppose there is a remedy for that in
that if the committee were minded to
refuse permission for this then it would
have to be pulled down but um if
enforcement with action was taken so
that that isn't something that you know
can't be resolved i suppose in the
future but i would yeah way in favor of
um deferring is proposed
thank you councillor thomas
thank you chair in light of the the
conversation that's come around the
table it is
both the applicant and
the objectives
the time constraints the object is
mainly because the building is is partly
in place
as we speak but in light of the
advice given by
ms colley i'll withdraw my emotions
thank you um
councillor bunting i think it's proposed
to furville i don't think it's been
seconded i'm happy to second that um
i suggest in the interest of just uh
proceeding with a meeting that we um
moved straight to a vote there um so it
has been moved and seconded that
um this application be deferred uh in
line with office of recommendation and
the support in that motion can indicate
now
okay that's carried thank you
um the next application for
consideration is 106 219 26 grain throat
road in amsterdam which is on page 103
of the committee report
before we have the discussion to this
application
it will be introduced by mr day
so we're just doing a technical hitch
with the slideshow
um
okay um
so
this application is part retrospective
and relates to the erection of a
single-story rear extension
to a two-story detached dwelling house
on the northern side of grange thorpe
road
the application has been reported
to the committee because the applicant
is a traffic council employee
and one objection has been received
a single story rear extension was
previously approved under planning
commission 101192
hha20
but the development has not been built
in accordance with the approved plans
the differences from the previously
approved development comprise an
increase in the height of the roof
alterations to the fenestration on the
rear elevation
and alterations to the positioning and
number of of the roof lanterns
the rear extension projects four meters
from the existing two-story rear
elevation of the dwelling
and measures 9.1 meters in width
which is the same as previously approved
the extension has a flat roof with a
total height of approximately 3.6 meters
3.25 meters not including the parapet
measured from the original ground level
the previously approved plans showed a
3.1 meter flat roof height
and the external ground levels have also
been raised by between 150 mil and 200
mil
the extension has been built in
brickwork to match the existing dwelling
and would accommodate an extended
kitchen and living area
it's considered that the pros extension
would be acceptable in terms of design
and visual immunity
and would have no unacceptable impacts
on the residential community of
neighbouring properties
it's therefore recommended that
permission is granted
subject to appropriate conditions
thank you mr day
note on the air there aren't any
speakers listed to um this item however
councillor procter has attended this
evening and advised that he did
um provide um a request to speak to the
item
uh on that basis i will take him on his
words of counselor potter if you want to
just approach the table you have five
minutes to speak
if you do run over time i'll just
politely ask that you wrap up your
contribution thank you
thank you chair yes something that got
lost i think in the in the effort but um
uh as it's been
stated online this application has been
reported to the planning and development
committee as the applicant is an
employee of the council and one
objection has been received i also asked
it to be called in the grounds of loss
of immunity following representation
representations from residents living in
neighboring properties
and a subsequent recent visit to the
site that i made
i'm here to speak against the office of
recommendations grant and hope
that the office the committee members
will agree with me
the application relates to a single
story rear extension and is a revised
scheme follow following the grant of the
previous planning permission
the development has not been built in
accordance with the original proof plans
with the differences from the previously
approved development comprising of an
increase in the height of the roof as we
have heard alterations to the
fenestration of the rear elevation of
the extension and alterations to the
positioning and numbers of the proposed
rule for london's
so this is essentially a retrospective
application
as construction has already been
completed and i'm sure that committee
members will have their own views
on the approach taken by the applicant
in respect of that
the office of recommendations
is assessed to be acceptable in terms of
design and visual immunity and has been
considered that it has no unacceptable
impacts on the residential immunity of
neighbouring properties and should be
granted
i would have however disagree with this
view and believe that the resulting
extended war now has a negative impact
upon immunity and creates an overbearing
aspect for neighbouring properties
and should therefore be refused
i'm not sure how many committee members
have visited development i'm sure if
anyone who would agree it was now quite
imposing and creates an overbearing
aspect for neighboring properties
the area look now looks quite crammed
the subject is obviously different from
other requests that come to the
committee and you can actually see the
reality of the development in reality
and it looks
forward to him from members particularly
those who have been there if they agree
with me that now creates a never
negative impact
the report considers the impact of the
proposal on 2428 green salt road as well
as 35 cumberland road
in terms of 24 grains up he's noticed at
the report that the height of the
extension adjacent to number 24 is
approximately 3.65 metres
measured from the original ground level
which includes the height of the parapet
it is acknowledged that this is
relatively high but considered that the
proposal would not have any unacceptable
overbearing or overshadowing impact on
on this neighborhood property
as a result of the existing rear
conservatory extension to north 24 and
the 700 millimeter distance to the sound
boundary of number 24. i disagree with
his conclusion
in relation to 28 grange thoughts
included that two 200 millimeter
projection over above the spd4 guideline
does not result in any undue overbearing
or overshadowing impact of the real
window or immunity space of number 28.
again i disagree with this view and i
feel like the impact will be
unacceptable for the residents of that
property
the impact on 35 cumberland is also
considered in the report whilst the
window arrangement of the rear ovation
is different from the previous approved
scheme it is considered that this would
not have any more impact in terms of
overlooking than the previous approval
as such has considered that extension as
built would not have any
unacceptable impact on the residential
immunity of number 35 of cumberland road
i also disagree with this conclusion
that the negative impact will be
acceptably high for the residents of
this property
as well as the other residents have
mentioned
concerns have also been raised by other
residents about the changes to the
design of the roof lights compared with
the approved plans
the report concludes that although they
are higher than the parapet they would
not result in any undue overbearing or
shattering or overlooking impact given
the position within the roof
again i disagree with this conclusion
and believe that they would have a
negative effect upon many of the
residents living in this vicinity
i do agree with the officers view at one
point that there is no impact on parking
with these plans not only residents have
raised concerns about this with me and
this doesn't seem to be an issue
as far as i wear the applicant has not
discussed these revive plans of their
neighbors and i know although they are
not obliged to
it might have made
made the changes more acceptable to some
of their neighbors
in conclusion i'm asking members of the
committee to go against the officer
recommendation and reject the
application on the grounds of amenity
for the neighborhood residents
living aside the approach the applicant
has taken to these provide plans which
is something i unfortunately could take
can't be taken into account here i do
think i've approved it this would create
an overbearing and cramped express spec
for neighbors which will be not
acceptable thank you thank you
councillor councillor minis
thank you chair um i just i've got one
question
um
is there a reason why it's been built
higher than it should be
like taller than it should be
um i've i've not been
so i've not been provided with
a specific reason
for that i'm
sorry
okay because
the reason why i'm asking that is
because obviously
when you you when you it's a flat roof
when you're doing when you're building a
extension you know
obviously the heights of a normal
ceiling and what it is inside the
existing house
and you're going to you make the plans
according to that
it got approved
it's now higher it does
i ca how close that house is to the the
neighbors
it does land up and it comes out four
meters
it does land up um
you know big
i think is is my issue i think that it
does land up overbearing
i
i can't i can i i absolutely actually
agree with cancer proctor there i think
it's just too
the extra height cause i'm just thinking
about my back extension and if i went
out four meters and went that high
i can get why my neighbor would be
unhappy with me i don't think she'd be
you know she's lovely my neighbor but i
don't think she'd be too happy i don't
think the one um from my corner the
other neighbor would be too happy either
um
so
i don't think it's okay to to you you go
and get one one thing approved
go build it bigger and then go hey can i
have it big can i have it
higher you must have known what the
height was i just don't
i'm not sold
thank you
i'll be proposing i can propose that we
refuse it if if anyone wants to come
along with me thank you
um okay councillor bunting
thank you chairman
um
i
can't see
where the objections are coming from in
relation to this yes it's a smidge
higher not a massive high but it's a
smidgen
the fenestrations have changed
that's no big deal and as for the roof
lights i genuinely can't see why the
room fights between exactly he's going
to bring the world down
um i
it was often a case where i
sort of sit here and i listen to ones
and i think well i
yes i can see your point but i don't
agree with you on this one i'm
struggling to see the point
i can't see why these relatively minor
changes are gonna make such a big
difference if this were brought to us
now
as is
for fresh application where there was
nothing built at the moment
would i have a problem with this as an
application well no i wouldn't so if i
don't have a problem with it in that
regard would i have a problem with it as
a as a
change yes councilman said except it
should it would have been nice if it had
been built as it was initially but you
can't turn it down on the grounds of
this retrospective that you have to deal
with retrospective applications in the
same way as if it was a
any other um
and i given the the setting and given
the
the the design and given the location
and all the factors taken into account
would these changes mean that i couldn't
have voted for the original or could
have voted for the original but not for
this and no i'd vote for this if it was
a new update i think it's a a reasonable
application to make and given the fact
chairman i cannot see
any
substantive reason as to why on earth we
could turn it down given the fact that
there was no sustainable planning reason
for refusal i'm more than happy to grant
to off to uh
uh propose we accept officer
recommendation and go for grant thank
you gentlemen thank you councillor
morgan
thank you chair um i slightly disagree
with councillor bunting um on this i can
understand
why neighbours
object to this um and i have to be
honest if it was a fresh proposal
i'd probably be a little bit more on the
fence um
but my question really is this question
really is
a rhetorical question maybe is what's
the likelihood to be honest if for
example this one to the inspector that
actually will be turned down we've
already got an approval which is it's a
minor amendment now i actually
completely agree with council and minis
in terms of i absolutely hate approving
retrospective planning applications
but
but fundamentally we we've i've i've
approved dozens and i've put not paying
for dozens but lots in my time on this
committee
i can't really see how we could turn
this down on just a minor amendment um
because we already have one
a planning um
application already here so i i i
struggle to see how we have any planning
grounds to turn this down based on
what's already been approved
thank you councillor dagnam
um
i'm sorry i don't know if this is a
planning issue or not i'm slightly
concerned about light pollution from
those two um
instead of one i can't remember what he
called it the little glass roofie thing
yes what we call it
a roof lantern sorry how romantic i'm
slightly concerned that
that would um
that would impinge on the neighbors
during the course of the evening on
bedrooms either side to have two of
those
quite so close
to the boundaries um not to mention
nature but there you go i don't
particularly like that addition when we
only approved one
there you go
thank you um councillor thomas
thank you chair again i disagree with
council bunting for the first time
tonight
the difference is half a meter
it's not not a smidge
i suppose you're not half a meter when
you're a meter away from it in your your
garden
um
just simple pythagoras has a half a
meter raised means your view your
viewpoint the overbearing of immunity is
massively varied
massively varied so
i i'm concerned that if he went to uh
appeal that he would be granted anyway
but
i am getting a little bit hurt at the
number of applications that we come
through that are minded to grant that
have
considerable variations to the original
planning commission in a day and age
where there's laser measuring tools
uh to ensure that you keep within the
parameters of the planning permission
you have
thank you councillor hartley
i i found myself agreeing with
councillor thomas on this it's not uh
it's not a minor variation is is sort of
half meter or 45 centimeters plus the
ground level has been raised slightly i
think i think that's a significant
difference
um and
yeah i you know people can make
retrospective applications for planning
permission i accept that but um
this isn't just a minor difference which
you know might be a build a
miscalculating or whatever it's it's not
noticeably and significantly different
to what was in the permission both the
changes to the bifold doors and the
windows and the roof lanterns
and the um you know significantly
uh higher uh per roof as well um
so i think when you when you look at the
increased height and i think you can see
this from the plans
i i have a lot of sympathy with what
council proctor said to us actually
because i think
it looks more like a
you know a one and a half story it looks
it looks
higher than a single story extension
that's that's the difficulty i have with
it
and
i mean there's other things i don't like
about it
the flat roof across the whole of the
back i don't think it's in keeping with
the with the house which is a hit roof
um
uh i i sort of take on board what
councillor dagner said about the roof
lanterns you know two roof lanterns is
different to one although i think the
original plans did have
um skylights uh on either side of the
the one roof lantern
um
and
it's also a quite a deep extension um
which is slightly over the limit um
so i suppose the difficulty in in i
guess is finding reason to refuse and
that and that's what i'm struggling with
because a lot of this
was approved under the previous
permission so the depth of the extension
uh was
the significant thing for me is the
change in the height and i think that
increase in height combined with the
the depth and and the appearance um
means i don't i don't think this is
clear cut and uh
yeah i welcome hearing what other
members say but i think i'm agreeing
with councillor thomas i'm still mulling
over in my mind what the
what the planning reason will be to
refuse
thank you council of acton
yeah i mean
i i have
concerns with this as well and i agree
with councillor thomas and
councillor hartley
and
i think there are reasons
there's one particular reason and i
think it's a good reason that the
extension wall now creates an
overbearing
impact on the neighbor
and
when you do look at it the the the
building as it's been
built
to me it doesn't look romantic
in fact i think it looks quite ugly
but
um
you know i i
i'm not clear obviously
um what would happen when if it goes to
the inspector but you know
is that
is that something that we have to
sort of consider
there is a consideration around that in
terms of expense i i recognize that but
you know that that's you know this
extension is going to be there for a
long time
thank you i suppose the main
consideration counselor acting and i
appreciate what everybody said is
have you got a really robust reason for
refusing permission and having listened
to everybody's concerns and i have to
admit i don't particularly like the look
of it from what i've seen but i don't
think i've heard a really robust case
for refusing permission this evening and
reading through the report as far as i
could tell i think the only um
aspect of the extension that isn't
policy compliant is just in paragraph 15
where they talk about a 200 millimeter
reaction projection beyond that which
spd4 would allow and would therefore be
policy compliant and
to my mind i i i don't personally think
i could hang um a
refusal and overturn of officer
recommendation just on that um deviation
from policy and for that reason i will
second counselor bunting's proposal that
we vote in line with officer
recommendation to approve the
application um councilman i know you
indicated before i'm going to bring
councillor welton first just as he's not
contributed yet
i think uh councillor talking indicated
before me
uh thank you council welton
mr deck can you clarify with this come
under permitted development but for
the applicant being an employee if
that's okay
do you mean would it come under
delegated powers yeah yeah
um
yeah so the original application um only
came to committee because
it was a council employee um
and and this this application wouldn't
have needed
to go to committee if it weren't up for
that fact yeah so
that was my
personal problem it is that although
i don't like the design
there's loads of things already built
so for us to turn
thank you i think that's a really valid
point councillor thank you i'm
councillor
welton yeah that's a really interesting
point thank you for that um i shall mull
on that for the next few minutes uh it's
really really really ugly and that
really concerns me and it you know it's
completely out of proportion with the
size of the house so the way the extent
the height of it now comes up to just be
underneath the window it's just
just just it just looks absolutely wrong
and i think the the pictures that the
um residents the neighboring residents
have sent in are really informative
and they they do show that it's it it is
overbearing
um on you know on their visual immunity
uh
i'm i'm incredibly
divided about this there's absolutely
you know there's actually no basis i
want this to go through on
um
i think it's you know i think it's it's
really poor practice that it's ended up
like this in the first place this is
somebody basically just trying to create
themselves a really really nice rumor
their neighbor's expense that's just
what i can see as far as this but i
totally understand that we don't want to
cause the council lots of headaches on
appeal
um
so i shall next now spend the next few
minutes dealing with my internal
dilemmas
and thank you councillor minis
i just wanted to say although i don't
like retrospective ones of course and
this isn't that's not my reason against
it because you know
the question like i was counseling said
if it came in
like this to start with would we have
said yes i wouldn't have done um
it's not a smidge it's 50 centimeters
that's like
at least five courses of brick like you
can't have just miscalculated and i'm
not buying that
um it's
a case of and when we're talking about
delegated powers that was a good point
um
but it would have been called in by
council procter so therefore it would
have come here so even if the person
didn't work here
i'm not trying to ignore the you know
it's not relevant the person works here
in that way um because it would have got
called in so
i think that you know we've got to look
at it as as is
to me the protrusion of the 20
centimeters you are building it to brick
if that makes sense so that that kind of
error can happen
the going up 50 centimeters no
that's you've done it and you've gone
at the expense as it were as the expense
of your your neighbors
i'm i'm not okay with it i think there
is a loss of amenity to the neighbor
it's very close they're all the houses
are close together i'm not it's it's not
a case of
and it is ugly but that's not that's not
again you know as a beholder and all it
is an ugly thing but it's it's the 50
centimeters too high
and what that causes to the neighbor is
my reason for refusal
if anyone wants a second maya suppose
that would be great
understood thank you councillor and
councillor bunting
well councilman got there before me on
the point the main points i was going to
make and so yes it could have been
called in and indeed it was so it would
have been here anyway so that was one
point i was just going to just going to
uh may continue this but all i'm just
what i'm just saying is that given the
circumstances and given the actual site
where it is yes i accept that this is
not a thing of beauty
um although given previous events this
evening it's slightly rich for some
councillors around this table to start
complaining about buildings not being
beautiful enough
uh i do think that given that
it does fit in yes i accept that there
were two two roof lanterns rather than
one
and but as the vice chairman has already
pointed out there would have been
skylights so you still have lights
protruding from the top regardless so if
you're looking down upon it you still
see light patches okay not two roof
lanterns you'd see
one roof lantern and two side uh two
roof lights so that'll be relatively
lingual you'd have to unless you were
standing in the garden looking directly
at the front of the fenestration is not
going to cause an issue to you and is
that a small addition in height
relatively small given
side to the building is that enough to
refuse on you probably have enough
difficulty trying to build a case for
enforcement if they just if we would
turn it down and they built it anyway
and you went to enforcement you'd
probably have enough difficulty trying
to justify an argument for enforcement
let alone uh
an appeal with the inspectorate so i
think uh the
reasons for refusal are
so weak on this one
we're just going to be throwing
taxpayers money away if we do
thank you
thank you councillor hartley
chad i just wanted to
respond to the point about um
if this hadn't been a council employee
it would have been delegated authority
and dealt with bad planning officer i i
don't think that is a good point i think
that's a bad point um because
that's the reason it's here because it
is a council employee um and
the you know the reason for that is so
that the council are seen to be being
open in its decision making and avoiding
any suggestion of bias and
actually i'd feel uncomfortable if this
was determined on the delegated
authority because it you know it's a
council employee who's built something
that isn't in accordance with the
permission they've been given
uh applying for retrospective planning
permission and if you know that was
dealt with under delegated authority i
would be uncomfortable with that so i
think it's i think it's completely right
it does come to the committee because it
is a council employee um
and i accept it probably would have come
here anyway but i don't i don't think we
should
uh you know suggest that we shouldn't
scrutinize it in full because ordinarily
it might have been dealt with under
delegated authority it's here for a
reason and that and that reason is right
thank you
yeah no i don't
take that point i suppose the issue is
we can't apply a different standard to
council employees because they're
council employees and yeah
maybe it's on both sides of the point
though um
councillor thomas the indicated speaker
yeah thank you chad we can't as a
committee start to
pass applications because it may be
scary costly on appeal
this
application retrospective or otherwise
has gone against original planning
permission
it's gone against considerably
on heights
and other reasons by fold doors
change the roof without consideration to
that there is no reason why
other than willfully doing it
making that choice to build higher than
the original plan application
to change the roof lights other than a
willful thing and i don't think that
because
we may be on the ground somewhere down
the line your contribution needs to be
relevant to the application not where
the transmitter is absolutely yeah okay
um
but we have spoken to this item quite a
while now there's been a motion
um proposed and seconded that
permission be granted in line with
officer recommendation there was a
counter motion proposed it's not been
seconded so anybody who wishes to speak
who hasn't contributed or has an
original point they'd like to make
no okay so we'll
move to the book
okay
so the
motion to refuse permission
um
this development has been second to bit
counselor walton
um perhaps between the two of you can
articulate the reasons on which you're
proposing i'd say loss of immunity to
the neighbor
because it's high it's overbearing and
it's messing
and it can either have loss of light
effectively because he's got a
monstrosity built next door
okay
i would ask members to moderate their
language when they're describing planets
you know these are people's applications
and and
um
you know we have to use measured and
balanced language as officers and also
as members um thank you
okay sorry massing um and and lots of
immunity through the nursing
okay thank you sorry could i just
clarify is that
do you say to the neighbors or neighbor
is it is it one is it both for which
neighbor
i'd say to both to be honest with both
sides of um the property
thank
you okay um so the reason is
for refusal would be loss of immunity to
neighbouring property is owing to height
and massing i think is there anything
that any other member wishes to add
no okay so we will take the motion to
refuse permission on the
reason just
stated first um if members who wish to
support that motion and refuse planning
permission can indicate now
okay
and then
members
who do not support that motion to refuse
can indicate
okay
okay
so that motion is not carried we'll now
turn to the motion
to
grant permission to develop
in line with officer recommendation if
members who support that motion can
indicate now
and members who do not support the
motion to grant can indicate
okay so that motion's carried and
permission to develop is granted um
we're now turned to final application
for consideration this evening which is
105 250 56 barrington mode in altering
them which can be found on page 41 of
the committee report
there are no speakers to this
application but before we turn to the
discussion um it is going to be
introduced by ms coley
thank you chairman
this application relates to a
semi-detached property on the eastern
side of barrington road
close to ultragum town centre the
property currently comprises seven
flatlets and one self-contained
apartment spread over three floors the
basement subject to the application is
currently
unused the surrounding area is
predominantly residential but there are
a few commercial uses within the
vicinity
planning commission is sought for the
creation of a self-contained apartment
with separate access within the basement
of the building
the proposed development includes the
creation of large light wells to the
front elevation providing basement
egress and an enlarged light weld and
basement access to the rear of the
property additionally soft landscaping
and secure bicycle storage are also
proposed on site
the application is reported to the to
the planning committee as an elected
member has an interest in the
application
one objection has been received in
relation to the loss of off street
parking the potential impact on
neighbouring roads
the proposals have been amended during
the consideration of the application to
improve the immunity of future occupiers
in terms of daylight and outlook by
enlarging the proposed light wells
the proposed development is considered
acceptable in principle as it would
provide an additional dwelling on
previously developed land within a
highly sustainable location
the proposals are considered acceptable
in terms of design and visual immunity
residential immediacy for future
occupiers and occupiers of neighbouring
properties and highway safety on balance
and given the lack of reasonable
alternative to a stepped access the
accessibility impacts of the proposal
are also considered acceptable the
application is therefore recommended for
approval subject to conditions thank you
chairman
thank you mrs collier there any members
counselor thomas
thank you chair um
having looked at the site and noticed
that again in the ar
that uh
equality was looked at
i accept that uh
in this situation in this case
that it would be very very difficult to
to install
whether either ramp or lift so i'm quite
happy to
propose that we accept the officer
recommendation
but like it noted that i'm glad that we
looked at the
opportunity regarding disabled access
absolutely thank you councillor i'm
councillor bunting
thank you chairman nothing really much
to say on this application let's help
you on moving things along and second
the proposal that's just been made thank
you
thank you are there any other members
wishing to contribute
no so it has been proposed and seconded
that um
permission be granted for development in
line with officer recommendation
um
can move to the vote i can't see anyone
else indicating they're desperate to
contribute okay so members who are happy
to support the motion for permission to
um
to grant permission can indicate now
thank you and
take that unanimous there's no members
voting against
um that concludes agenda item six um
agenda item seven is urgent business we
have received um one item which relates
to an update regarding an appeal at the
former b q site in stratford um
this item will be introduced here well
the item is a report however is going to
be introduced by ms cauley
thank you chairman um the report before
members this evening is an update in
respect of the progress and the
council's position on an undetermination
appeal by a crew
forum
uh following the committee's resolution
in october that they would have been
minded to refuse a planning application
at the former b and q site on great
stone road a reminder of of the
proposals that they were for the
demolition of the existing retail unit
in associated structures erections of
buildings for a mix of use including
333 but now 332 apartments communal
spaces ancillary to the residential use
flexible space for use classes a1 a3 d1
or d2 undercroft car parking new public
realm and associating engineering works
and infrastructure
the application wasn't outlined but
sought permission for access layout
scale and appearance
with only landscaping being a reserve
matter so it is essentially a full
planning application in all but name
the appeals proceeding by way of public
inquiry and the deadline for exchange of
proof of evidence is uh tuesday uh the
14th of december so next tuesday which
is why this is coming to members as an
urgent item
um the public inquiry opens on the 11th
of january next year and will sit for um
three weeks one in january and two in in
february
um lancashire cricket club
uh are an active participant in the
inquiry they've been granted rule six
status that means they'll participate in
the inquiry be represented by their own
council and give formal evidence and
they intend to give evidence on noise
which is the matter before members this
evening
um when members originally were minded
to refuse the application uh
they did so for for seven reasons those
reasons set out paragraph five of your
report i don't intend to go through
those in in detail again now
only to say that um in terms of the way
the inquiries progressed and this is
quite nor this is quite normal as as um
evidence is exchanged and moves along
the council has determined under
delegated powers which we're able to do
that we wouldn't pursue um reasons in
relation to the impact of the
development on the um
on on the cricket the visitor experience
at the cricket club nor on heritage
because of we've had further evidence in
in the way of verified views which shows
that the impact of
on those matters is lesser
than was first
envisaged however
evidence on noise matters has has moved
on um substantially and recently as well
originally the council's environmental
health officers didn't raise any
objections to the proposals on noise
grounds
um they thought that uh noise impacts
from the cricket cluster this is from
activity at the cricket club on future
residence of the development they
thought that could be mitigated
up to and as far as concept noise
um but they didn't think that constant
noise in itself
on the seven occasions
in the year that it was able to
take place was sufficient to refuse the
planning application uh that was the
conclusion of the officer report and
that was the conclusion that members
carried through
when they were minded to refuse the
application
however
since then um
the um lancashire club have uh confirmed
that they wanted to make representations
and they made their representations and
in in those that includes a new and
substantive
noise report uh by an acoustic
consultancy called vanguardia and that's
referred to as the vanguardia report
and they also asked us as the council to
review that report and to update our
position if we if we saw fit
their particular concern is the agents
of change principle
and that's that's a fundamental
principle which is in the national
planning policy framework which means
that if a new use moves in next door to
an existing use which can cause nuisance
or
um or similar or and in this case noise
impacts it is up to that new use
to to mitigate the impacts of that noise
or or whatever it might be on
uh on that use not
the responsibility of the existing use
which is already there so the appellant
in the agent change principle has to
ensure that residents are protected from
the noise that might arise from the
cricket club to a to a degree that that
lancashire cricket club
would not be required to curtail their
activities because obviously that that
um
that's not not deemed to be a fair way
of going about things you move and you
say you can't do this anymore and then
somebody has to close down and
move out and um a real life
um
example of this which is recently in the
news is about night and day in
manchester it's exactly the same thing
um
so the vanguardia report
uh established a number of issues
with the noise assessment that the
appellant had um
had produced
and uh again they're set out in your
report i don't intend to go into those
in in any detail that's at paragraph 12.
um and
the
the our our environmental health
officers reviewed the report and they
agreed with vanguardia they said yes
there are issues here um we agree with
the with the agents of change principle
we are
um and we think that there should be
conditions for mitigation uh on on on
the building which will
allow
um lancashire club to continue their
um
their activities uninterrupted
um
and then
the
the appellant put forward an updated
acoustic design statement
um which suggested that
there was there was mitigation that
could be provided in a certain in a
certain way
which would protect the
residents up to 80
decibels uh la eq 15 minutes um
which again is at paragraph 15 and and
that was and that was their view
however
uh our environmental health officers
still considered there were there were
big issues with this report in terms of
the terms of mitigation
um and because it's a particular quite a
specialist area they suggested that
the planning service commission a peer
review which we did from from a company
called sandy brown who assisted us at
number one old trafford and you'll know
there's a relationship between number
one old trafford and victoria warehouse
where you equally have an event space
and we we had the same issue so we knew
that that they were capable and uh able
to do this kind of work
um so
the the peer review effectively um
demonstrated or
to us that the music noise from the
concerts is of particular concern
in terms of what impact it might have on
the cricket club because
uh it's their their conclusion was that
the noise from concerts would be um
would not be able to be mitigated
without significant changes to the
building if those significant changes of
the building
didn't take place then um noise
complaints were likely
those noise complaints could lead to
review of lancashire's premises license
and could tell their activity because um
it wouldn't necessarily we can't take
the planning app permission away but but
we we can uh and and in response to
noise complaints uh could be obliged to
change their premises licence and
therefore it would fail on the agent's
change principle
in the same way that the committee
considered the application that's in
front of them the inspector is also
going to consider the application that's
in front of them
if if the application needs to be
significantly and materially changed in
order to um
put in the appropriate noise mitigation
um that's um that's not
the application in front of the
inspector it's not the appeal scheme is
not implementable
um
and that will and the council has also
spent a lot of time putting together a
very detailed um proof of evidence on
design if the design changes then then
all that work is is prejudiced and the
council is prejudiced as a
as a party in the inquiry so
that's all summarized paragraph 21 which
um
sums up why
we think that there should be this
further um putative reason for refusal
um so that's the noise impacts from
activity at the cricket club would have
a harmful impact on the immunity of
future residents of the development
given the above noise complaints are
likely which could lead to the review of
lcc's premises licence and therefore
applying the agent to change principle
lcc should not be required to curtail
their own activities to accommodate new
development
and even if a planning condition is able
to deal with the masses above the
impacts on the design and layout of the
development are currently unknown and
the proposed scheme may not be
implementable although it's an outline
application the appellant seeks approval
for the matters of appearance and layout
a revised scheme to accommodate
appropriate acoustic mitigation would
not necessarily be the scheme now in
front of the inspector for example it
may change the proportions of
fenestration to solid wall construction
and late changes to the design and
layout of the scheme would prejudice the
council's well advanced and detailed
case on design being put forward of the
inquiry it may also work worse than the
design impacts of the proposal by for
example requiring large stretches of
solid wall
thus we think that um officers recommend
that we do take up this particular
reason um that it's robust and and it is
of significant concern so we recommend
that you authorize officers to do that
and if you are minded to do that then we
will
tomorrow update our statement to case
and we will call um
sandy brown limited um to give evidence
on the council's behalf at the public
inquiry
thank you
thank you miss coley um
yeah and i hadn't sort of connected the
dots about the similarities with night
and day in town interesting um so
committee's been asked um
to authorize the planning and
development department to add noise as a
refusal reason um
during the appeal process for the bnq
application that has previously been
refused um
i think there may be some questions
comes the punting indicator before yeah
i've got two if i may uh the first is
isn't it rendered rather mute given the
fact that large-scale objections are
pretty much guaranteed given previous
events to come anyway even if that
building didn't exist if there was
nothing there
you're going to get every resident in
the area complaining i know they did
last time i remember we discussed this
previously but i remember coming down
and one of the
concerts was on and it was ear splitting
in the town hall
uh you know
so quite [ __ ] i felt truly sorry for
all the residents in the area regardless
of this new building about whether that
was there or not so given the fact that
they're going to be lots of complaints
against lanky chicago club guaranteed
next time i held a concert
and they're probably going to be asked
to mitigate what they're doing anyway
they might be
moves to stop them doing it it's
irrelevant whether that goes in again
against this application because the
agents of change argument doesn't happen
doesn't really carry that much but
because it's not like it's it's not an
issue at the moment it's already an
exten an existing issue they're already
gonna be asked to change what they're
doing i'm sure next time they put an
application into whole concerts there
will be a barrage of complaints
yeah it would be a case of every council
in these buildings after duck and cover
to avoid being bombarded by
uh complaints left right and center so
that's one one problem in terms of this
if it was a beautifully quiet area that
never suffered noise before and then
suddenly bang then you could see the
agents of change being an issue
the other problem is in terms of
and it is an existing another objection
to
the uh all that or the existing refusal
if you will that we're trying to
challenge what's the position regarding
the way you voted previously because if
you voted for it last time i think i did
then you didn't vote to refuse it in the
first place or should you now be
agreeing additional comments
enter or an additional refusal reasons
given the fact that you didn't vote to
refuse it in the first place so those
two
problems if i may
yes certainly um
the difference being here council
bunting is that the
impact at the moment is on
existing residents who are there now
so the um
the consideration is is different the
agents of change principle is a very
specific
planning policy principle which applies
to new development so that so there
would be
um
in in terms of them curtailing their
activities
and and the other point being that this
is all this is almost right on top of
the um
of the of the stage i accept that point
but given the fact they're gonna almost
certainly has to curtail their
activities anyway
by the existing residents who already
lived there who were sick and tired of
it last time it happened where you could
literally you couldn't have a
conversation in the streets outside this
building because you were literally
being deafened by the noise
um i don't i don't think we could the
thing is we can't say that at that point
well i was here it was
witnessing it what i mean is we can't
say we can't say this eve this evening
that that there would be
that the
noise complaints from existing residents
are going to curtail lancashire's
activities we
we can't say that all we can all we can
do
is say that if
this particular development goes ahead
and the sound in there is not mitigated
and they complain
that could
be because because they are a
uh because they
are
effectively
so so close to the development and it's
not mitigated and it is the appellant's
responsibility to do so so it was so
when
when planning permission was granted for
lancashire's activities
in in the first place
that is imposing lancashire's activities
onto
um existing residents and therefore
lancashire's responsibility
to mitigate that this is the other way
around
because this has come later it is the
appellant's responsibility to mitigate
and what we're saying is the appellant
has not
demonstrated that they have
appropriately mitigated and if they did
so and if they do so
that changes the scheme
to such a significant degree that it is
not the scheme in front of the inspector
so we can't reasonably impose a planning
condition if we can't reasonably impose
a planning condition
then
you either refuse the application or you
accept the harm and if you accept the
harm you come back full circle to the
agent of change principle
um
i accept your point uh i think you're
entitled you're entitled to disagree
with my my point can i accept your point
but given the fact that effectively all
you're going to do is reduce the number
of you're basically taking out do you do
something that will increase the number
of objections well you're already going
to get a vast number of them anyway so i
accept the point and i'm not wholly
disagree with them saying it's not maybe
as black and white as is in other cases
what about the second point now i ask
you
can come to if if you don't feel
because you didn't vote to refuse the
application last time that you should
not participate this time that's
entirely for you to make that decision
right thank you thank you um councillor
hartley
um
my question might be partly answered by
the last bullet point in
paragraph 21 which talks about um
in order to mitigate the noise um
it you know require significant changes
to the design and that prejudice is our
case in the design so i i get that i
think um
so i guess my question is
if if we add
noise as a reason piece of reason for
refusal
does that
prejudice our position as a planning
authority
in
what we do with that bq site so are we
accepting that
residential development is not going to
be possible on that site or are we
saying
it could still be possible with a
different design that had sufficient
noise mitigation etc
yes we we have never objected to the
principle of residential development on
that site the point on design is that we
don't know what the impact is we put
we've um that impact could be
significant it could be more harmful
that might also be a function in the
scale and muscling of the building which
we also object to so it's so it's very
tall and that obviously the
the impacts are different because of the
lack of scripted screening so it's all
kind of linked up together in that sense
thank you um counselor thomas thank you
sir uh i also thought a night a day as
soon as all this so it was uh
a shame uh just again a bit a little bit
more clutch on uh council heartless
point
the sandy brown associates statement of
case
is basically what we're saying is we are
protecting
lancashire club and others
from
having
complaints made about them from the new
development
to affect their business
yeah exactly that yes in that case i'm
happy to support this and the proposal
we do
okay i'll second that motion um comes
the
are there any other members wishing to
speak to this item
no okay so the
recommendation
is that um
[Music]
the committee authorized officers to
pursue noise as a further putative
reason for refusal at the upcoming
public requiring respect of this
planning application um
motion is that
that
recommendation be supported
members happy to support that can
indicate now
okay
and those not happy to support and
counselor hunting
on the grounds the tides make it clear
for the record on the grounds that i
raised under point two of my query to
mrs coley i am not taking part in this
vote as it would be a nonsense for me to
do so
thank you thank you councillor um so
that concludes the business for this
evening's meeting and we'll now close
the meeting and hope everybody gets home
safe thank you